et à new york toujours la vie a repris
très vite une façon de montrer qu'on ne
se laisse pas abattre une forme de
résistance encouragé par le maire de la
ville reprendre coûte que coûte ses
habitudes son travail
yasmina farber edwards père un étrange
climat étrange ambiance à manhattan new
york tente de retrouver cette énergie
qui la caractérise
mais assurément le coeur n'y est pas si
le business a repris c'est surtout parce
que tout le monde ici veut retrouver ses
repères
je pense que les gens essaient de
reprendre leur routine quotidienne
c'est difficile de ne pas penser à ce
drame
dès qu'on se réveille mais chacun sa
façon de le gérer pour la plupart le
travail est la meilleure solution pour
se déconnecter haye union square des
messages désespérés pour retrouver un
proche disparu le world trade center
de tempérament pressé le new york est
devenu le concerné c'est comme si les
gens étaient perdus chacun est dans son
monde veut pas croire que tout cela a pu
arriver
en cette journée de recueillement la
routine s'arrête pour apporter un
témoignage de solidarité aux victimes
mais aussi pour raconter ce qu'on a sur
le coeur je suis new-yorkais américain
est fier d'être new yorkais ils sont
entrés dans mon jardin
alors je suis en colère je ferai tout ce
que je pourrai pour riposter
malgré la tristesse c'est d'abord la
fierté qui s'affiche dans les rues de
new york
c'est comme si new york où il vit un
cauchemar tout éveillé mais tous ceux
que nous avons rencontrés nous ont
raconté le même rêve américain
tout recommencer pour reconstruire